you say you know is a new this is really
good I've never had dulce de leche
before but I did take three years of
Spanish and so I can guess that this is
some sort of combination of milk and
sugar of course I love to say that I'm
Latino as [ __ ] this is caramel what is
it
this is dulce de leche this I'm guessing
this is flan with dulce de leche oh my
god it's almost like sinful peanut
butter it has a texture of peanut butter
but I feel terrible about myself when I
eat it I don't like this part but this
part is great the actual dulce de leche
that's amazing it like doesn't scream in
your mouth oh my god I'm sweet it's
mostly like hey girl I'm a hug your
taste buds is that putting the two best
things together it's like a Biggie and
Tupac made a song together
yes yes I don't know what to think about
this but I want it in my mouth Oh Oh my
Bob this is the best thing ever I'm not
even being extra mm-hmm so good it's
like flaky and again sugary and sweet
but like not too sweet I don't want to
try them these other things because I'm
really into it the dulce de leche is
sandwiched between like two cookies and
then it's like drenched in chocolate or
meringue like what more do you want in
your life these look like little
Oreos Oreo Plus this dulce de leche
stuff like I feel like I'll never eat
Oreos again well what is inside of it so
caramel okay
just kidding Argentinians this little
old warm chewy kind of like eating a
Snickers I imagine I'm allergic to nuts
so I don't really know what that's like
it's honestly like eating an amazing
like chocolatey dulce de leche cloud
it's like a amped-up Girl Scout cookie
okay this is love who needs
relationships I've had kind of like the
Mexican version of dulce de leches but
I've never had it like combined with
like this Argentinian spin the legend on
everything is a genius idea
I can't believe they had this in
Argentina I never tasted
[Music]